(host)
Maybe it's the unblinking eyes
staring at you
emotionless day and night.
Or perhaps it's
their small size acting
as a cloak of innocence,
or their human-like
appearance that makes them
seem just slightly too real.
However you want to spin it,
there's something
creepy about dolls.
Why do we take these
seemingly innocuous things
and give them such life?
And why do we continue
to imagine them
as capable of evil and violence?
[upbeat music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
As imaginary others,
it's easy to ascribe meaning
onto the artificial body.
In addition to ritual
and religious use,
dolls might have been
the very first toys.
Archeological evidence shows us
that the ancient Egyptians,
Chinese, Minoans,
and Etruscans all produce
dolls for spiritual purposes.
The oldest we have found so far
dates to the third millennium.
While early dolls
were sometimes used
for sinister purposes
much more frequently,
they were used for protection.
In the third century BC
the use of dolls
in spiritual practice seems
to take a negative turn,
at least in literature.
In the second Idyll collection
of the Greek poet Theocritus,
part of the narrative details
a witch using a wax doll
and a nefarious love spell.
Roman poet Horace gives
a similar malevolent cast
in a 30 BCE text
in a story of necromancy
and erotic magic,
where two female witches
use a woolen doll
and a smaller wax doll
in a mock execution.
Stereotypes and
demonizing rumors
about religious and spiritual
dolls like voodoo dolls,
kachinas, corn dollies,
and puppets
have undoubtedly contributed
to negative associations,
particularly their
false connections
to demonic witchcraft
and spirit manipulation.
Views of spiritual practices
that use figurines or dolls
as conduits or ceremonial
figures negatively
may have bled into cultural
attitudes towards dolls
designed for entertainment
and the consumer market.
Human miniatures first
served ritual religious
and funerary purposes.
But beginning in
medieval Europe,
miniature fashion dolls were
collected by wealthy adults.
Doll maker became a profession
by the early 15th century,
and doll houses
emerged in Europe
around the 16th century.
When the fashions they wore
fell out of favor,
the dolls might be passed on
to children as play things.
This history contributes
to an uncertainty and
unease about dolls.
We aren't sure of their purpose,
at least not entirely.
Dolls have always been
in-between objects
and that makes us uncomfortable.
There's something about a doll
that can give off a creepy vibe,
especially in recent times,
but why?
The first ventriloquist dummy
shows up around
the 18th century.
I know technically
it's not a doll
but a puppet,
according to enthusiasts,
but they don't fall far
from the uncanny valley
family doll tree.
These dolls come alive
with movement and a voice.
A ventriloquist's
performance is in part
dependent on the audience's
willingness to suspend disbelief
and see the doll as
a sentient person,
or at least detached
from the human operating.
It often made to look like
a child or child sized.
The ventriloquist dummy calls
to mind a youth possessed.
Baby dolls and porcelain
dolls became popular
in the 19th century,
followed closely by socketed
joints, movable eyes,
and talking dolls.
What was also developing
around this time
the modern concept of childhood.
Before the
Enlightenment Movement
of the 17th and 18th century,
many people just
didn't subscribe
to the cultural
concept of childhood.
It was only when philosophers
presented the idea
that human experience
defined knowledge and reason,
that people really
began to consider
cultivating an ideal childhood
for personal development.
Children became
seen as blank slates,
which meant that what
they played with mattered.
This is when dolls become part
of children's
developmental play,
and it's when things really
take a creepier turn.
So another reason
for our fear of dolls
is partially about the weariness
of the child
and of childhood itself.
Children, like dolls,
seem innocent and naive,
but we can't really know
what they're thinking.
Dolls when seen as tiny humans
emphasize this same point.
This attitude becomes apparent
as literature starts to emerge
blurring the boundary
between child and doll,
questioning what is
a living thing and what is not.
Just look at "Pinocchio."
First published as a magazine
serial in 1881 and 1882
and collected into
a single novel in 1883,
"The Adventures of
Pinocchio" follows the story
of a marionette doll crafted
from a talking piece of wood
that wept and
laughed like a child,
a terrifying little
tidbit excluded
from the Disney
version of the story.
Oh, and Jiminy Cricket.
Yeah, in the original story
Pinocchio kills the talking
cricket with a hammer,
and that's only the tip
of the creepy iceberg
and the unintentional
horror story.
Before becoming a real boy,
the doll experiences some
pretty traumatic stuff,
contributing
to the story's questioning
of both morality and humanity.
While Pinocchio
the talking sentient marionette
was firmly grounded
in the pages of fiction,
real-world dolls were
becoming more human-like
by the addition of voices.
The end of the 19th century
gave us the first talking dolls
from an unlikely source.
After inventing the
phonograph in 1877,
Thomas Edison invented
a talking doll
who got her voice
from a tiny version
of his earlier invention.
While Edison thought
the doll would be a hit
in the late 1880s,
he was grossly mistaken.
Dolls bridge the boundary
between child and adult.
Sometimes they have
adult-like features
on a child-sized body.
There's also the way
kids play with them,
caring for them like
children of their own
or crafting fictional
adult lives to act out.
It blurs the child
and the adult too much
for us to be comfortable with,
and we're right back
to that uncanny valley.
Take the infamous
Robert the Doll.
Gifted to Robert Eugene Otto
by his grandfather
around 1904, the doll became
the boy's constant companion.
He talked to the doll and
treated it like a real person.
He even gave the doll
his name, Robert,
and began calling himself Gene.
Human Gene blamed mischief and
accidents on Robert, the doll.
Part of a wealthy and eccentric
family in Key West,
rumors about Gene
and the doll flourished.
Robert stayed a part of Gene's
life into his adulthood.
Children would report seeing
the doll standing by himself
in the window of Gene's house,
seeming to move on its own.
After Gene's death,
the new owner of the house
and the doll reported hearing
footsteps and giggling.
She also saw the facial
expression change
if anyone spoke poorly of Gene.
Many creators have
used the story
as inspiration for all
kinds of terrifying stories,
but none as famous as Chucky--
the killer doll that
launched a franchise
and gave pretty much
everyone nightmares.
Hi, I'm Chucky. Wanna play?
[screams]
So living dolls are getting
the public's interest
in literature
and eccentric real world tales
in the early 20th century,
and film
wouldn't be far behind.
Dolls firmly entered
the horror genre in 1945,
the important British
horror anthology
"Dead of Night" ends
with the creepy tale
of the relationship between
a ventriloquist and his dummy--
a relationship that
questioned who was the master
and who was the puppet,
and who was the murderer.
A few decades later,
the "Twilight Zone"
a series that does
excellent work
turning the mundane terrifying,
aired a standout episode
that took a doll
from merely creepy to evil.
In "Living Doll," Annabelle
buys her daughter Christie
a Talky Tina in an attempt
to distract Christie
from the harsh parenting
of her new stepfather.
The thing is,
Talky Tina isn't happy
about Christie's mistreatment,
and the doll begins
to move on her own tormenting
and threatening the stepfather
before eventually killing him.
The episode's final words
come from the doll herself.
In 1969, "Playboy"
got into the doll game,
but not probably
in the way you're thinking.
Famous science fiction
and horror writer
Richard Matheson published
a short story "Prey"
in the April edition.
In the story,
a woman named Amelia
buys a Zuni fetish doll
named He Who Kills
as a birthday gift
for her boyfriend.
Described as "seven inches
long and carved from wood
"with a skeletal body,
oversized head, pointed teeth,
"bulging eyes, and a tiny gold
chain wrapped around its body,
keeping the spirit
inside from escaping."
When the doll falls
from the edge of a table,
the chain slips off.
The doll stalks
and hunts Amelia
with supernatural speed
and ferocity,
injuring and eventually
possessing her.
And this horrific variation,
the doll's malevolence is
formed from a misunderstanding
of Zuni practices.
The story took on new
life when it was adapted
for television as "Amelia" in
the 1975 "Trilogy of Terror."
The doll's physical appearance
is significant in this time.
It is muscular,
shirtless, and black,
a racist take on the tale
as the doll stalks
the white Amelia.
In the sequel, "He Who Kills"
from the "Trilogy of Terror II,"
the same doll hunts
a white Dr. Simpson
and now has a cannibalistic
need for flesh--
another damaging
and false stereotype.
The 1970s marked a return to
the creepy ventriloquist dummy.
In William Goldman's
novel "Magic,"
a struggling magician
buys a foulmouthed dummy
that may or may not be alive.
A story of suspense,
the reader is left wondering
if the magician Corky is really
a violent mentally ill man
or if the dummy fats is
behind the murders he commits.
Anthony Hopkins would star
in the 1978 film
adaptation that gives us
yet another truly creepy doll
for our nightmares.
It also marks a change from
the demonic possession trope
and into conversations
about psychopathy and trauma--
topics under scrutiny as
a handful of serial killers
are discovered across the globe,
including John Wayne Gacy
and Ted Bundy.
And in 1982, "Poltergeist"
just really puts the cherry
on top of
the child monster doll deal.
Robbie's murderous
clown doll manages
to combine two terrifying
monsters-- the creepy doll
and the killer clown--
into one epic jump scare.
It gets me
every time I watch it--
literally every time.
[evil doll cackling]
And I think one of the reasons
it's so incredibly
effective as a monster
is because it strikes when
Robbie should be sleeping--
snuggling safe in his room,
his mother just down the hall,
relaxing in the bath.
Dolls often reside in
playrooms and bedrooms.
Spaces in the home meant to
be safe havens for children.
But sometimes real human
monsters violate that safety
and the evil doll can be
a metaphor for that offense.
The 1980s also brought
one of the most iconic killer
dolls in history-- Chucky.
"Child's Play" takes
a serial killer
and places his ghost in
the body of a talking doll,
literally bringing
the killer into the home,
disguised as
an object of comfort.
In an additional
element of horror,
while the audience knows that
the doll is the real killer
within the world of the movie,
the police are convinced
that Chucky's owner,
a child, is the murderer,
presumably driven
to commit violence
because of the trauma
of losing his father.
If you're a parent,
it can often seem
like children have a death wish,
and it's not that far a mental
leap to imagine the inverse
of that murderous intention.
I'm looking at you,
sleep deprivation.
Chucky launched
a successful franchise
that served up scares
alongside social commentary.
Chucky's sequels are a satire
on heteronormativity that
challenge the very concept
of life by disrupting and
questioning conception itself.
In "Bride of Chucky,"
female doll Tiffany gives birth
to a doll child.
"Seed of Chucky" continues
the story of Tiffany's child,
who has ambiguously
gendered and sexed,
and on a journey to
find their doll parents.
When this goal is achieved,
the child, alternatively
called Glen and Glenda,
brings their parents back
to life with a ritual,
essentially rebirthing
their own parents.
Then the dolls capture
actress Jennifer Tilly,
playing herself, who
is forcibly impregnated
with Chucky Seed and gives birth
to human twins who
are then possessed
by the spirit of the doll child,
who I guess was
born with two souls--
one male and one female.
But yeah, the movie was marketed
at gay pride parades alongside
special Chucky condoms.
The "Child's Play" remake
brought attention back
to the franchise in 2019,
but it was really the
"Chucky" television series
that continued the
franchise's queer history.
So this doll is made into
to a monstrous other
that challenges human
relationships and norms.
Another part of the fear
of dolls, I believe,
comes from conceptualizing
them as empty human vessels
we can ascribe meaning to.
A child plays with the doll
and makes up a whole history
for their play thing.
But there's a fear that
the doll will come alive
with a vengeance, unhappy
with the life it's been given.
The interesting
array of creepy dolls
from the 1990s
highlights this anxiety.
A killer ventriloquist dummy
in "Tales from The Crypt"
is revealed to be
the ventriloquist's
murderous Siamese twin.
Slappy from 1993's "Goosebumps:
Night of the Living Dummy,"
inspired in part
by R. L. Stine's fear
of the original Pinocchio story,
is a sadistic dummy who fights
another animated dummy,
Mr. Wood.
The two girls who own the puppet
spend much of the book
trying to convince the adults
around them that
the dolls are alive
and that Mr. Wood is trying
to make them his slaves.
The idea that dolls
could be alive
took a much more PG turn
in 1995 with "Toy Story."
Well, kind of.
The vengeful, mutilated,
and tortured dolls of Sid
swarm the boy
in a scene that seems
straight out of a horror movie,
complete with exorcist
spinning head reference
and zombie-like toy soldiers.
(Sid)
Ahh!
I know this movie is
why I became hyper aware
of how I was
treating all my toys
for fear that they would come
alive at night and attack me.
The 21st century is certainly
not lacking in
scary doll stories.
The uncanny faces
of dolls appear
in massive horror
franchises from "Saw"
to "The Conjuring Universe,"
and most recently, "M3gan."
All of these stories
explore family, faith,
and the lingering effects
of acts deemed sinful
either spiritually,
socially, or intellectually.
The dolls and all of them act
as surprising containers for
violent and deviant behavior.
The doll becomes a monster
only because of a human's
fear, the terror of childhood,
the possibility of malevolent
intent in a small body,
the misguided intentions
of burgeoning identity.
It is our discomfort
with the uncannyness of their
humanness that unnerves us,
especially when there are
artificial motivations
to closely resemble
our own dark urges.
Hey, friend.
Before you go, we want
to hear your feedback.
Every year PBS Digital
Studios surveys our audience
helping us understand
what you enjoy on YouTube
and what you want us
to make more of.
You also get to vote
on new show ideas,
so it'd be great
if "Monstrum" fans
were represented in the polls.
There's a link in
the description.
Thanks in advance.
The doll becomes an-- oh.
[crew speaking]
Ah! Aah!
Hey.
Ah! [laughs]